have you your firm or anyone you  currently or have previously employed  been contacted or subpoenaed by the  Justice Department or the FBI no not to  my knowledge not to your knowledge so  for example no i don't i have no no one  at Pershing Square has been contacted by  the FBI ah well what about you disappear  what about consultants who you've worked  with like global strategies group Evelyn  mantilla my understanding is global  strategy group has been contacted by  either the DOJ or the FBI I'm not sure  which one and some of their  subcontractors have received subpoenas  and you have paid global strategies  group to do what they're a government  relations firm and they consult on and  help advise with respect to you know  dealing with the government and you know  state local federal as well as lobbyists  and you pay them to help you with the  herbalife campaign that's correct